Here, have a couple questions for you. First, if you haven't ridden a bike in
years, but when you get on it you remember exactly how to ride it, what types
of memory are activated? But then you remember the first time you ever rode a
bike. What type of memory is activated here? Finally, little random but, where
are the Great Pyramids? What type of memory is activated when you recall this?
Take your time, but for the question, if you have not ridden a bike in years.
But when you get on one, you remember exactly how to ride it, what types of
memory are activated? Type in two answers. And then for the next question, you
remember the first time you ever rode a bike. What type of memory is this? Just
choose one type of memory. And finally, where are the Great Pyramids? What type
of memory is activated here? Again, choose one. Here are four options to type
in the boxes. Episodic, implicit, declarative, and procedural.